okay
i'm good donna can you give me one clap
please
here we go
one two two five six seven
powder your nose and get your mask off
if i'm talking in this voice does it
sound like i'm shouting you're filming
all this right i want to make sure
yes let's get going all right everybody
as a journalist the thing you want to do
as a reporter and as a journalist is to
bear witness
when there's a big fire burning we run
towards it
when a bomb goes off we run towards it
oh god the smell the sound to cover it
to find out what are the implications
for
people
that's
what we do so i guess you could say
journalists are sort of drawn to
disruption
for two decades the disruption in the
world has been continual
it just never stopped
[Music]
at 15 minutes away from six there's the
view beautiful just a few clouds around
the area let's get into what's happening
through british columbia right now
welcome everybody to our brand new
facilities here at global bc in
vancouver any preview isn't complete
until you've had a sneak peek at what
you're going to see on your television
sets on monday so come on this way i saw
that
the global network was wanting to become
national this really is a remarkable
studio people have put in long hours to
make sure that we can stream web video
and that one of the things that they
agreed to do was to create a
national newscast
the countdown is underway global
national is only hours away and i had
just bounced uh badly out of hosting
good morning america
and i wanted to come home
one minute to the opening one
we wanted to disrupt the television
landscape a little bit in canada by
putting national news on the dinner hour
and we wanted it to have a very
different voice well we didn't want to
give people just
here's a list of things that happened
today we wanted to put it in context we
wanted to tell people here's how it
affects your life people are getting
ready for work it's time for kids to go
back to school and it's time for global
national to take its first few baby
steps
[Music]
when i look at the early stories the
first six episodes of global national
news was softer when global national
first went on the air
and so that original plan that we spent
five months thinking about
and executed for all of
six days
uh was for an era that it turns out
didn't last very long oh my god my
goodness
a second plane now he's crashed into the
other tower of the world
would have been packed with people at
this hour and we don't know
how many people were aboard the jet this
is no accident this is no bomb from
inside this is as you put it a terrorist
attack there's no two ways about it high
[Music]
alert hello
people are screaming down uh heading
away from the world trade center let's
go let's go back up
uh
having heard the second blast
people are running some of them running
now firefighters are in there for a
major fight the stairwells of course are
how people are going to be evacuated
people will be evacuated out of these
buildings
and it was stunning
i remember someone walking into the
control room looking up at the screen
and saying
oh my god those are people jumping from
that building we go back to that picture
please uh in the control room it's
difficult to know let's take it full
frame if we can please but it looks as
if that second tower has either had
sections of it fall off or has just
collapsed
that stays with you just
oh my goodness what is going on
i was sitting on the anchor desk looking
at the city i'd lived in
not even a month ago
and now i was looking at towers where i
knew some of my friends worked
but 9 11 happened i was in the tel aviv
bureau of nbc news and
like everybody in the rest of the world
we were just glued to our televisions
[Music]
an unbelievable scene in new york city
you can see the whole lower part of
manhattan at this hour engulfed in smoke
and flames as the second section of the
world trade center has apparently
collapsed in flames so when we got to
liberty state park on the jersey
shoreline it was it was a view you were
basically looking at
the city of new york
burning
the odor
like the smell of
of smoke is one thing right a campfire
smoke that's one thing
but the smell of um things that aren't
normally on fire on fire
uh is something you don't forget
where are you
what happened what the building
collapsed part of the building collapsed
it was hard we went on for 16 hours
and
we did we didn't buckle
but after those 16 hours
uh i drove home and it was a beautiful
sunny
blue sky day in vancouver with the north
shore mountains and uh i pulled over the
side and
i cried uncontrollably for about 30
minutes elizabeth rivas knows the
chances are slim but clings to hope her
husband might still be found alive
but he can be injured and maybe they
don't have his name we started bumping
into people that were
panicked at locations throughout new
york the lineup stretched sometimes
around the block with people looking for
any news of their loved ones this woman
was trying to find out about her brother
he's light skinned with freckles and
they would walk right up to the cameras
and just hold it in front just desperate
and and overcome with
with i guess it was the grief um you
know i've never seen that kind of grief
in that
volume um before
this is what it's like when a war is in
your home
[Music]
i think after that it almost said well
almost anything's possible
it just changed the you know the whole
potential for
what could happen next
i think that pre-911 uh life felt safer
uh
i think journalism seems slower paced
when global national went on the air
that's kind of the experience that i
expected it would be
but then
9 11 happened
and then
afghanistan war happened and then iraq
happened and then it was just one major
crisis after another on top of each
other
we we couldn't catch our breath
tonight war is inevitable
evacuations of westerners underway in
iraq president bush preparing to issue
saddam hussein the final ultimatum a
third of our naval warship fleet has
been committed along with planes and
some special
forces from the east coast three
frigates a supply ship and a destroyer
equipped with sea king helicopters are
heading to the persian gulf and the
mediterranean
[Music]
it's calmed down a little but uh still
hairy still a little nerve-wracking for
a lot of the people here we had another
several missiles come in today just
watching those very powerful bombs um
take out
major installations and and the palaces
in in baghdad fighter jets bombing the
capital cabin and other cities
the story that i will never forget from
afghanistan is march 8 2008. we went out
to kandahar to see how women in 2008 in
afghanistan were acknowledging
international women's day and we went to
this compound where you're behind a
closed door and we sort of waited there
was a first event happening just wait
here we're going to have speakers people
will come
and you're wondering who will come there
was just women coming out
from all over the place and the thing
that stood out for me from that is
the bravery first of all that there
would have been to leave their home and
come celebrate women when women are
absolutely not celebrated by so many in
that country at least not by the taliban
regime and then there was this woman who
did an interview with us so she's not
only brave enough to come out she was
brave enough to show her face
and talk to us about what life was like
to be a woman in afghanistan in that
time and she talked about how women were
treated like dogs that was her word were
but not like a dog like a pet like a dog
that you kick a dog that you beat when
it's down and you hurt again and you
treat just like this animal living in
your home and so
for me i can see her face i can hear the
cadence in her voice and every
international women's day since hasn't
passed without me thinking about her and
wondering
after she went home what happened to her
almost in a daze he tells global
national the same thing twice
robin the whole point of operation was
tarik is to win over the afghan people
the canadian addition to maxim
30 000 people cross here every day and
most of them get by with a wave
people saw it and they knew that they
knew we were at war but they didn't
really process that until we started
seeing
those absolutely
heart-wrenching
repatriation ceremonies that were just i
remember every
every single one i ever watched and and
they were
a feeling we hadn't experienced as as a
nation before
ramp ceremonies like the one that
happened here today are unfortunately
becoming part of our national experience
[Music]
the vehicle trooper mark wilson was in
struck a hidden mine or bomb on saturday
he was helping to build a road in the
dangerous panjoy district
in our five days of broadcasting from
afghanistan his was one of three deaths
all members of the royal canadian
dragoons all killed helping to construct
that road while i was in afghanistan i
had the absolute honor of covering the
story of when some families came to
visit
and there was a memorial and then they
spent some time at the um
at the wall where all the pictures are
a compulsion to see and stand in the
last place their loved ones did brought
17 canadians to kandahar airfields tim
goddard's daughter nicola was the first
canadian female combat soldier to die in
battle
nicola goddard's dad was there my wife
sally
decided that she didn't want to come
she feels
at peace with things as they are i felt
the need to come it was it was just a
lovely service and i remember standing
in the background and my sunglasses on
because i'm just bowling
so so the children's i had one and uh
my uh my wife got it for me and nicola
always used to laugh about me wearing it
and so i thought it was appropriate to
wear it today i think this is the other
part that people don't realize
is that
we're so stoic on camera
but a lot of times
we we wear a lot of the stories that we
cover
to really understand afghanistan you've
got to get outside the wire
we were out on patrol in a village a
couple times with matt da did you say
you're just for audio your name and uh
rank sure captain matt uh
that's pretty good good
not bad
sorry man
i'm just gonna throw myself out here so
how did you guys sleep last night
all right matt
was 27 at that time when he and i met
and uh right away right away you could
see the leadership skills there our
platoon right now is providing security
on the uh on the flanks for these guys
as they're going through
how did i find out matt was killed so it
had been about two weeks since i last
saw matt
uh and i was uh
sitting at home and i turned on global
nationals a day off for me
and then i saw the story
and it hits you so hard
that young man
was quite young probably didn't remember
his dad
but boy would i tell
him lucas how are you bud
good you good first of all just uh
absolute pleasure meeting you really is
yeah thank you
i can talk a little bit about your dad
and my time with him if you're okay with
that yeah that sounds good what really
uh impressed me about him was
that he sort of embodied
core canadian values small town canadian
values whatever you want to say he was
just a really
nice decent guy
he's the kind of canadian you wanted
representing this country in those
villages in afghanistan he exemplified
everything that was uh
true and right about our nation we're
not a perfect country but we're a good
country we're a caring country
filled with really caring people i'm
just curious what kind of things you
think you'd like to do in the future
i was i like police officers like i'm
kind of looking to something like that
because i want to help out in the
community and especially with things
going on right now i kind of want to fix
all that and just kind of fix everything
yeah and i want to be involved like in
the community and kind of just get out
and just experience things good for you
all your family's got such an amazing
record
and history of public service uh that
doesn't surprise me thank you
just wanna if you roll i'll just get a
question the uh
this place is not very big when i was in
afghanistan one of the things that i
found myself hoping was that maybe
someday when my kids were 18 or
something
i could go back there with them and the
things would have improved
enough for that
maybe we'd fly into that kandahar
airport the civilian side
fast forward to today
that's not happening
for some reason when i look back i think
of my kids and go that's too bad that
was
what i was hoping for and i guess it was
way too optimistic
how has it come to this
this is just horrific
they have nothing to lose
these people are human shields and
they're just moving with all their heart
all their might like it's their last
night here
[Applause]
tonight on global national
[Music]
engulfed in flames forest fires whipped
by high winds devour a huge chunk of an
alberta town look at this
a whole bunch of fire highway 88 right
here
and people are looking to get out good
evening we're coming to you tonight from
athabasca alberta where one of the three
evacuation centers has been set up for
the thousands of residents forced to
flee slave lake
other than get out of here
i think the biggest disruption in our
lives
it's happening in slow motion but the
biggest disruption in our lives is
climate change
these are the smoldering remains of
slave lake burnt buildings charred
vehicles a ghost of a town seven
thousand once called home this is
probably the worst curveball nature has
ever thrown at us
and joining me now is shelley doucet
she's one of the people forced to flee
last night along with her young son
three and a half year old aiden shelly
give us a sense of how much notice you
got none none none
we've covered more storms than i can
count
over the last 20 21 years extreme storms
you cover each one and no one feels
qualified to say
this is climate change because it's that
cumulative body of evidence but you look
back at all the stories you covered and
all the people in every story saying
we've never seen anything like this
[Music]
hurricanes
snowstorms wind rain storms surges
[Music]
in the village of dunroven 53 homes were
hit by the ef-3 tornado on friday
and you think about those in combination
and you think yeah that's pretty
compelling evidence
when you've covered flood after flood
after flood after forest fire after
drought
after you know um pests
um taking over farmers fields because of
um you know whether pattern changes
you just sort of shake your head and be
like are we back here again are we
really telling this story again haven't
we learned anything donna it is it is
chaos really you hear the emergency
sirens going but i need to show you it's
not just on the border this is fort
mcmurray burning when reed did that
one live hit
where we could see the flames behind him
approaching
i think i looked a bit stunned on air
because i recognized what was happening
i didn't want to panic him but what i
really wanted to say was reid could you
just stop talking and get out of there
but donna look at that like that
even in the past five minutes has just
flared up and uh to be honest i'm not
sure how long we'll be able to stay here
but it shows how quickly things are
changing
[Music]
it was a
incredibly
dramatic moment
hey
[Applause]
i think in the time that i have been a
journalist the biggest change has been
again because of technology because of
the internet and because of cell phones
with cameras so
they made everything much more present
they made uh made it possible for us to
see what was happening on the street
immediately
global national from london here is
donna friesen
good evening tourists are fleeing egypt
by the thousands tonight
i remember thinking um when that first
began to happen
especially in the arab spring we relied
so much on citizen journalism and there
was so much hope
and so much of a sense that this could
be transformational for these people who
had been
oppressed and suppressed by their
governments well first of all just
getting into egypt as the arab spring
was accelerating we realized very
quickly we cannot walk in like
traditional media anymore we can't bring
that bulky eng camera that we all carry
that's quite large
[Music]
[Applause]
it's much too dangerous for us to
venture outside today so we're stuck
here in the hotel with the rest of the
foreign media watching this incredible
drama unfold looks like uh
the fighting has picked up again in fact
it hasn't really stopped it's a bit of a
lull but
this is something i have never
seen in my life this is absolutely crazy
just nuts
us being out there
is just not a good idea right now
journalists western journalists have
been attacked assaulted
uh our vehicle today was surrounded by
pro mubarak youth about 25 of them we
were basically held hostage in the
vehicle for about 25 minutes
no no we are filming for global
television from canada we are here to
film uh canada canada yes global
[Music]
so that weekend alone i remember going
this is absolutely crazy we're not
carrying a bulky camera around so in
this case uh our photographer barry
acton and myself we walked into that
protest and that rally with two iphones
and we filmed our entire story relying
on two phones
i'm happy and i want more i want more
ragda and rauda are part of the wired
opposition they don't hesitate in
telling you who's responsible for this
historical moment young people on the
facebook yeah
so you use facebook and yeah facebook
and twitter so there was a growing media
ecosystem within the middle east as well
on top of
um twitter facebook and many other
social media that were just starting up
so the entire media ecosystem was just
starting to be disrupted and hosni
mubarak and his regime did not know how
to deal with that
i remember being in sri lanka opposed
the tsunami boxing day tsunami and we
were trying to find a way to send our
story back military had set up blockades
at almost every road they don't allow
for the foreign people they are
free
so are our driver and translator if
they're caught helping journalists they
could go to jail but they agreed to try
and show us something just as long as we
agree not to show their faces we found
this company to send our story back and
we called the
satellite guy i don't know who it is we
called the person in charge of trying to
help us get the story back and he said
you need to get to the e6 satellite and
we ended up doing six bounces i believe
like around the globe where the story
got sent you know to space and over here
and then above china and then down and
over to america and finally the story
you know a couple minutes later is in
vancouver so that to me was like oh my
gosh wow look look what we can do and
then next thing you know a few years
after that you are on your phone
taping yourself filming yourself talking
about an event and the story is there
within seconds or you're live streaming
it what cameras um in the hands of
people have done of course is take us to
these immediate
unfolding events
at one point he runs through a glass
door then back into the street towards
officers
that's when several shots are fired
floyd was arrested after being accused
of using a counterfeit twenty dollar
bill an officer knelt on his neck while
he begged for mercy
one of the things that's happened with
everybody being witnesses and everybody
having access to video and being able to
share it
has been that the definition of who gets
to decide what news is
has broadened considerably and so
nothing
really escapes
the eye of the witness anymore in this
world
check his book check his right hand
check his calls how has citizen
journalism changed everything i think
you should just take a look at the black
lives matter movement
if those people weren't recording those
things
we wouldn't have the evidence
it's so important because so many of
those people didn't get their stories
told and they were just immediately
shoved aside and
the stories were covered up frankly
you know technology is is usually what
what leads to
um rapid change in society wake up wake
up
[Music]
it is the reason
a white police officer in minneapolis
was convicted of murdering george floyd
it was because of a person holding up
their phone and taking a video of that
[Music]
you are fake news
[Applause]
alternative facts it's the only true one
that is telling the truth yes and it's
going to save us all
all right
all right eric it's kevin can you hear
me yeah i can hear you and i'm good
we're good here all right
all right okay
tonight on global national
standing by a building built by slaves
an african-american is sworn in as u.s
president i barack hussein obama do
solemnly swear our team of
correspondents will bring it all to you
tonight but let's begin our coverage
with our washington bureau chief eric
sorenson eric
kevin as a staged event the inauguration
was exceptional but as a moment in
history it was truly extraordinary i
remember
barack obama
in his campaign
had used twitter
and uh that was 2008 and i'd sort of
heard about it i didn't think it was all
that important but for the inauguration
uh the obama team was tweeting out uh a
lot of their messaging for the first
time
and they were tweeting out
pictures of him behind the scenes for
the first time so i thought i'd better
get on twitter we integrated into the
newscast we were one of the first to do
it
because it seemed to be a really
useful tool and it used to be
good to interact with your viewers
in in a substantial way
and then it stopped being good and then
it started to be harmful
and then it started to be dangerous
and i think that's where we are now i
have a love-hate relationship with
social media so i um
that it continues to this day from my
perspective my personal brand is sort of
who i am as a person
isn't what's important for the job that
i do the importance from my perspective
is really delivering information to
viewers and
my ability to do that is not you know
increased if i have a big social media
profile
i think it can be so destroying and i uh
i just don't need that in my life
facebook was great initially because you
could connect with all your friends and
twitter was amazing as a journalist
because you were basically getting a
live feed from witnesses on the ground
of of news events that doesn't make it
easy it particularly doesn't make it
easy as a woman because things are said
about you that tend to be said far less
about your male colleagues
comments about your looks
comments about who people assume you
might be in a relationship with or
trying to undermine people by saying
well their husband or their boyfriend or
oh they're probably sleeping with so and
so
it's shocking when you see this
and it's it's purely being done as a
tactic to try to discredit you it's
vulgar but trending often hurled at
female television journalists if they're
spotted in the field this toronto
reporter could have swept it under the
carpet like women have been doing for
centuries i'm sick of this i get this
every single day do i feel as safe doing
my job today as i used to
no
i don't they'll say the worst things
like well they shouldn't be allowed in
this country or they
put all this bigotry onto the internet
all these horrible comments
and trying to police those is not fun in
my time i worried about people being
overseas that their danger would be
there
i didn't dream they might be attacked at
rallies here
not just verbally not just online but
perhaps physically
and that's a scary thing
it was a bit of an eye-opener to me just
how dark parts of the internet became
and have become
the fort hood killer and the time square
bomb suspect plotted their attacks using
the internet the russian spiring
employed internet cafes to avoid
detection increasingly criminals and
extremists are exploiting the internet
to communicate anywhere and everywhere
you look at how somebody in a basement
in downs view
can be radicalized
by the places of the internet that they
can go to we saw
the results of that
when there was an attack on our
parliament the gunman somehow made it
past security into center block just as
government and opposition mps were
holding their weekly caucus meetings
the gunman was shot dead in a dramatic
shootout in the hall of honor
he's been identified as michael zahaf
bibow
a parliamentary guard was reportedly
shot in the leg shaken mps barricaded
themselves inside meeting rooms while
others managed to evacuate
but we're seeing that now too and we're
seeing that primarily around white
supremacists and young white men who are
being radicalized in tribes and in
societies and
in um
ways that is massively disruptive to
the world that they actually inhabit
on this monday night from washington d.c
just hours left in a relentless campaign
we are going to win four more years from
my news perspective the presidency of
donald trump was
a non-stop
disruption
team trump calls the media dishonest the
media called the trump team's assertions
falsehoods and trump aide kellyanne
conway explained it like this and you're
saying it's a falsehood and they're
giving sean spicer our press secretary
gave
alternative facts to that but the point
remains
alternative alternative facts is that
emphasizing different facts or is it
just contradicting genuine facts it's
the only true one that is telling the
truth yes and is going to save us all i
think the time where i realized how
pervasive misinformation is and how it
often comes from really common sources
was actually attending a trump campaign
rally uh right at the tail end of the
2020 campaign tell your governor open up
your state open up your school
and we were in uh north carolina we went
to this rally and every single trump
supporter i interviewed
would come up with the same answers to
my questions are you worried at all
about your safety being here today
packed together in a crowd no not at all
not at all will you wear a mask
no i think that there's a lot of other
more pressing issues than the pandemics
and they were specific statistics and
specific facts
that were all false they were not true
but they were rhymed off as the answers
to every single question i asked about
every issue ranging from
joe biden to the pandemic to the economy
we are
behind him 100 percent the u.s is doing
more than your gov your canadian gov you
know
population
and they were all stats that they had
heard on sources like fox news or one
america news or the more fringy networks
or on facebook coming from the trump
campaign and you realize what a fight
we're up against as journalists to tell
the truth i was you know i spent a lot
of time covering russia and that meant
spending a lot of time covering
disinformation and you know these really
concerted
multi-million dollar campaigns to try
and
confuse us as canadians and americans to
try and you know sow division
just a short drive from the famous
palaces of st petersburg is an ordinary
office building that's become infamous
this for rent sign adorns the former
home of the now notorious russian troll
factory which the u.s accuses of
meddling in its 2016 presidential
election and where vitale bisfala used
to work my job was to write 20 news
articles a day full of pro-kremlin
propaganda he says and then share the
articles using fake online accounts i
created with photos taken from real
profiles usually women because they were
considered more trustworthy i remember
like just being amazed at how
easy it all seemed it was
it's sort of like they would just find
other people's photos online from real
profiles they would use those to make a
fake profile and then they would start
using hashtags and start promoting false
information and then that information
would get retweeted not only by other
trolls but by literally millions of
other internet users
you know give vladimir putin
credit
for figuring out that he could
disrupt
uh so much of
western
democratic society
at such a low cost
disruption is
creative rihanna taylor ahmad aubrey
disruption is destructive
[Music]
disruption is opportunity
people here in the square who have a
whole new hope and they're so eager now
and it's exhausting
[Music]
nothing in
decades
has disrupted
humanity
and the way we live our lives the way
the pandemic has
even if you haven't become sick your
life life has been affected because your
life has been
become so limited and so restricted
i don't think we'll fully understand the
impact of it
until a few years from now
[Music]
pandemic was a confluence of so many
story lines there was tragedy with
people dying there's science with the
vaccines there's the economic factors
here and then our personal lives were
affected
i didn't see friends for months
at least three patients who had traveled
from central china have been
hospitalized in both thailand and japan
do not travel outside canada there are
also new travel protocols that will
affect all overseas flights to canada
and all cruise ships that want to dock
in canada
they are going from one 14-day
quarantine to another after two weeks on
what some called a floating prison i
don't mind this 14 days both myself and
my wife we agree that we should take
this extra 14 days to be
virus free
the first death in canada was at a bc
long-term care facility i want to start
off by
letting you know that we unfortunately
have had to death here in british
columbia i remember when our public
health officer dr bonnie henry had to
tell the media
in her daily briefings that it had
happened and she broke down
and i remember we all sort of took a
pause and i had a pit in my stomach i
actually felt really sick about it
because i thought this just isn't the
first time she's gonna have to deliver
this bad news
and it went on and on every expert i'm
talking about here the more i'm learning
about this suggests that uh we're coming
to a place where you know working from
the office for most people is not going
to be feasible anymore
[Music]
hey i found you
you sure did working from home will
either drive us batty or get us to laugh
at silly things
we used to have a section of
the newsroom where we all were together
sitting close
right next to each other
zenyu is that their thing
with the pandemic about 75
of the staff in our building
uh is working from home or just remotely
and so that meant a lot of empty space
[Applause]
i think the first wave was was scary
because we didn't know what was going on
i mean we still didn't really understand
this virus and what we were dealing with
and i was terrified about bringing that
virus home to my wife and newborn
um by the third wave we knew what we
were dealing with in a sense but i had
seen the hospital i had not seen that
hospital as overwhelmed
this toronto hospital is jam-packed
that alarm ringing through the halls is
code blue a man in his 40s just arrived
with a suspected case of covid19 and his
heart stopped staff in the emergency
room inserted a ventilator tube and
saved his life while other patients are
lined up in the hallway just outside
there were more younger people in there
they were getting sick faster we were
hearing stories of people dying at home
if you walk the halls of the icu you can
see up close the changing face of this
pandemic we were here in the first and
second waves where you largely saw
elderly patients sitting in these rooms
but these days there are a lot more
people who are younger i've gone you
know sent to iraq when isis was there
um
been been in hostile environments before
but then you get back on the plane and
you go home and
and there's a bit of separation whereas
obviously the pandemic
there really is no escape
after 9 11 and and with the threat of
terrorism for years my grandmother used
to say um i i don't understand how
people can bring up kids it must be so
hard with all these threats and i would
say grandma you grew up in scotland
during the blitz you had a bomb shelter
in your backyard
we're okay
the pandemic is the first time where
i've thought oh you know what
this is comparable probably to what you
know grandma went through
it is a question of value to quote oscar
wilde do we know the price of everything
and the value of nothing
when this coveted crisis is over there
are deeper questions to tackle about the
worth of heartfelt hands-on work
for now what we offer those doing
essential exhausting work
is profound gratitude
tonight
when you think back 20 years i mean
there's a whole lot of trauma
that you remember but i got to say what
mostly comes the forefront is the
crazy
time you have
trying to do what you do
so we had so many great moments i
remember very early 2003 we thought like
why don't we put five people in a bus
with chairs that like won't
go down so they can sleep and let's do
36 remote shows for an election across
the country going west to east
like that that was nuts that was crazy
okay real fast
but my favorite story involves uh
somebody who is behind the camera right
now kurt brownridge
we were on a leer jet and
we found out from the from the pilot
that if you shotgun a beer on takeoff it
goes down with g-force so of course you
had to try it
and i think kurt you cheated
cheated a little bit cheated a little
bit but it was
one of those uh
crazy wonderful moments that in
the passage of time with all that we've
been through together
um
those are the memories that stick the
longest
[Music]
say yeah yeah
oh
can i tell this on camera
[Laughter]
jamie lost his passport the night before
we went to rusher he got on some boys
weekend or something with that you were
filming all this right i want to make
sure
the time i almost missed the prime
minister's plane in japan coming back
because we were at the sake bar trying
different kinds of sake it was great
or then we got sent to iraq and realized
he forgot his computer cables
he was driving around a market in her
bill trying to find another computer
cable
i was able to change my clothes
uh in the bathroom of the car rental
shove them into the garbage box there um
get into the car drive do my story
i was thrown up on and i still filed my
story
when you look back on it
you know
the exhilaration or adrenaline
can take you a long way
and also just sort of reflecting on
i don't know how we were able to pull
that off it was the best
um
i loved it i've worked with a lot of
great guys i still believe fundamentally
you know after all the stories i've done
of horrible things happening and
people dying and you know
terrible acts of violence um perpetrated
on other people i still believe
fundamentally in the goodness of
humanity hey my pleasure so great to
meet you thank you so much i often
describe to my friends the hamster wheel
of news that we're constantly doing this
just trying to keep up with the volume
which seems even more
like a fire hose these days than it ever
has been and so uh to take those moments
to look back and
see what we've accomplished and the
stories we have delivered and the
the moments of of
anguish in people's lives the moments of
agony but also the moments of real joy
over the years is is
makes it all worthwhile
[Music]
so
you